they're making some headway on those
california wildfires but it's continuing
to impact our air quality
now you mix that with the heat ted and
it's really hazy out there so
let's check in with you now for a look
at our forecast yeah we have a little
bit of wind out there and some more for
tomorrow but really not helping with
that smoke out there that air quality
advisory
specifically the smoke advisory still
remains in effect through tomorrow we'll
see if that gets extended
moderate levels of smoke still out there
and that doesn't surprise me because of
course
like denise had mentioned the fires are
out there here's our smoke tracker you
can see
the wolf fire this is the creek fire
down
south here see that drifting upwards
towards us that's the bobcat fire and
east of us just south of mesquite we've
been tracking this
this is the virgin fire south of
mesquite still burning
that smoke drifting off towards the
northeast it's going to be a warm night
tonight in those mid to low 80's mainly
clear skies with that haze out there
but winds should die down even more late
tonight and 77 should be our
nice comfortable temperature at 8 am but
the heat is still sticking around
i'm going to show you the numbers we're
expecting for this week and also next
in your most accurate forecast